ومشاهدينا باسلوب يجمع بين الوثائقي
والمتخيل اعلنت قناه الجزيره الوثائقيه عن
انطلاق العرض الاول لفيلم الحمراء وابن
الخطيب وذا الكاف في المنطقه العربيه
والذي استغرق انجازه سبعه سنوات وهو اضخم
انتاج لقناه الجزيره الوثائقيه في عام
2022 اليكم القصه
كيف السبيل الى الخلود في عالم الفنان
كيف لنا وشمسنا في غروب ان اختم هذه
الرحله بصوره تنطبع في ذاكره البشر
انا لسان الدين ابو عبد الله محمد ابن
الخطيب وزير هذه الدوله وحافظ سرها
ايضا
[موسيقى]
من الامر اشبهه بتشهيد بروج في السحاب
تنتصب الحمراء شاهده على ايام ربيع اشرقت
فيه انوار
كريم
تربتنا كلها خير
بدانا من طينها الذي خلقني واليه
[موسيقى]
اذا التصوير تم في قصر الحمراء الذي وصفته
المخرجه بانه اصعب مكانا يمكن الحصول على
ترخيص تصويرهم فيه لولا الحظ وفيروس
كورونا الفعل هذا ربما كان من جوانب كوفيد
الوثائقي حيث سمحت السلطات الاسبانيه
بالتصوير بسبب اغلاقه مؤقتا عن الزوار
وحول تفاصيل هذا الفيلم الوثائقي الحمراء
وابن الخطيب ينضم الينا مدير قناه الجزيره
الوثائقيه احمد محفوظ
سيد احمد اهلا بك صباح الخير مبروك هذا
الانجاز الضخم الاضخم في تاريخه الحمد لله
مبروك للمشاهد العربي مثل هذا الانجاز
لانه الحقيقه نقله نوعيه في صناعه الافلام
الوثائقيه العربيه حتى وان كنا شركاء في
هذا الانتاج ولكن يبقى انه هناك اضافه
نوعيه على مستوى الانتاج وعلى مستوى
الشراكات التي دخلنا فيها وعلى مستوى
المضمون هذه الفتره لم نستطع ان نتحدث
عليها قبل بهذا الشكل الضخم بهذا الشكل
المحترف انجاز التعبير والذي يخاطب
المشاهد العربي كما يخاطب المشاهد الغربي
الغربي في ان واحد متبنيا وجهه النظر
العربيه والاسلاميه في التاريخ والتي
افتقدنا ان نتحدث عنها وعن انفسنا
سنوات من العمل من التخطيط من التصوير وها
هو ابصر النور اخيرا لو حدثنا اكثر عن ما
الذي يميز هذا الفيلم من ناحيه المستوى
الموضوعي وكذلك الفني والجانب التقني
والتصوير الحقيقه هم الجانبين يشكلا اهميه
كبيره في انتاج هذا الفيلم الجانب الاول
هو الجانب الموضوعي وهو الاهم بالنسبه لنا
اذكر ان اول ما التقيت بالمنتجه والمخرجه
من حوالي ثمان سنوات وكان الحديث حول هذا
الفيلم كمشروع والحقيقه كنت متخوفا لان
غالبا ما يتم تبني وجهه نظر واحده او
احاديه الاتجاه في مثل هذه الاعمال والتي
نحن الحقيقه او تاريخنا طرف فيها فكنت
الحقيقه متخوفا حتى استطعنا ان نصل او ان
اتاكد ويتاكد فريق العمل معي ان الامور
ستخرج بالشكل الذي نرتديه وبالشكل الذي
يليق بقناه الجزيره الوثائقيه والمشاهد
العربي اذا هذا الجزء الاول اما الجزء
الثاني فهو له علاقه
بالانتاج واداره الانتاج نحن نعم نحن
مشتركين في الانتاج نحن هذا ليس
احاديا اللي انا او انتاج حصريا فقط لنا
ولكنه انتاجا مشتركا مع الكثير من القنوات
العالميه والدوليه والتي الحقيقه وجودنا
فيها من الاول ساعد ان هذه القنوات تدخل
معنا على الخط وعلى خط الانتاج مع المخرجه
والمنتجه وايضا ساعد ان تكون ان نحافظ على
الخط التحريري للفيلم اذا
الناحيتين يعني يكمل بعضهما البعض الناحيه
الفنيه والمحتوى والناحيه ايضا اداره
المشروع واداره الجانب التحريري وهو ما
اسميه انا ربما يعني يعني اضافه الى
الشاشه العربيه والمشاهد العربي طيب السيد
احمد البطل القصه شخصيه ابن الخطيب هو
مفوخ اطيب مفوه ووزير يعني سياسي واديب
ومؤرخ يعني هي شخصيه ثقيله في التاريخ
الاندلسي وغرناطه تحديدا التي كانت تحولت
من الحضاره من الاندلس بعد سقوطها في يد
اسبانيا النصرانيه بين قوسين الى
تحولت الى غرناطه وتركزت فيها الحضاره
الاسلاميه هناك حيث عاشت اخر ايامها للاسف
لكن اختيار مثل هذه الشخصيه بالذات ما هي
دلاله التي يحملها ما هي الرساله التي
اردتم ايصالها للمشاهد العربي الرساله
كانت في كما ذكرت حضرتك في لسان الدين من
الخطيب نفسه وفي لكي يكون اطلاله على
طبيعه العالم في هذا الوقت او طبيعه
العلماء في هذا الوقت هذا الرجل فقيه
سياسي مهندس يعرف في الطب وطبيب وكان
يعالج وكل هذا ذكر في الفيلم الى الى اذا
وشاعر ايضا جادك الغيظ يعني عنده عنده
الحقيقه يد بيضاء في الكثير من العلوم هذا
هو العالم
الاندلسي في هذا الوقت هذا انعكاس او يعكس
ان هذا هو طبيعه العالم العالم ليس الفقيه
المتخصص فقط في الفقه مع كل الاحترام او
متخصص فقط في الموسيقى يعني عندما ترى ان
هناك مخطوطه اندلسيه
انا رايتها بعيني فيها الحروف حروف
التعليم الموسيقى
حركات الموسيقى وعندما سالت عن اي شيء هذه
المخطوطه قالوا انها عن تعليم التجويد
تجويد القران بالموسيقى هنا يكمن الامر ان
هذه كانت طبيعه الثقافه طبيعه المثقف في
هذا الوقت ليس فقط رجل الدوله الغارق في
السياسه ولكنه هذا هو طبيعه المثقف هذا هو
طبيعه العالم وليس فقط وليس متخصص في
متخصص يعرفوا في الفلك ويعرفوا في الطب
ويعرف في الفقه وهذا وهذا ماذا يعكس ما هي
الدلاله حول ذلك هذا هو سؤال حضرتك هذه هي
ثقافه الاندلس او هذه هي
التفوق التفوق وهذا هو
يعني يعني
المخرجات المخرجات التي
افاد بها ثقافه وحضاره الاندلس الثقافه
الانسانيه والحضاره الانسانيه بشكل عام
وخصوصا انطلاقا من اوروبا طب كيف كانت
ردود الفعل بالنسبه للجماهير هل وصلتهم
هذه الافكار ما مدى تجاوب الجمهور مع
العرض الاول لهذا الفيلم الفيلم الحقيقي
كان مليء بالرسائل يعني من يرى الفيلم
ويشاهده هناك اكثر من مستوى لرؤيه الفيلم
سواء على مستوى رؤيه
الاحداث او على مستوى رؤيه الرسائل او على
مستوى رؤيه بعض المفردات حتى على مستوى
اللغه وكان هذا وصل بشكل كبير انما
الحقيقه انا ساقول لكم مشاهده عجيبه جدا
اولا اللي حضر العرض الخاص اللي انا شفته
بعيني في الدوحه عدد ضخم جدا من الناس
متفاوتين متفاوتين سواء على مستوى الثقافه
على مستوى السن
رد الفعل منهم جميعا كان ايجابي جدا هذا
واحد الامر الثاني وهو الحقيقه الاهم
بالنسبه لي ان رد الفعل المشاهد الغربي في
اسبانيا كان عاليا جدا حتى ان الفيلم
عندما طرح بتذاكر في صلاه السينما حصل ان
يكون او اصبح او كان هو واحد من اهم عشر
افلام
اقبالا في البوكس اوفيس او اقبالا في
الدخول للسينما في الشهرين الماضيين اذا
هناك
فضول للناس عايزه تعرف وايضا في نفس الوقت
هناك احترام
للعمل احترام للمشاهد احترام
للناحيه الاداريه في العمل كانتاج وايضا
الناحيه
التحريريه
نحن نسعى الان
الحقيقه في التعاون مع المخرجه هناك عده
عروض ستكون عروض دوليه يعني في بعض
البلدان وقد يعني نحاول ان يكون في بعض
البلدان العربيه ايضا كعروض بريمير يعني
كعروض افتتاحيه ثم بعد ذلك ان شاء الله
يعني نتمنى ان يكون على اخر هذا العام او
على الشتاء القادم في على شاشه قناه
الجزيره الوثائقيه باذن الله
دوام التوفيق والنجاح لكم شكرا جزيلا على
وجودك معنا في الجزيره هذا الصباح مدير
قناه الجزيره الوثائقيه احمد محفوظ شكرا
جزيلا